at their council meeting in Brussels on  Monday the 9th of March EU employment  and social affairs ministers will debate  the employment situation and social  issues in the context of the 2015  European semester exercise for example  they will evaluate what measures need to  be pursued in order to better adapt  working careers to new requirements  including technological change and an  aging population as the employment and  social situation continues to cause  concern ministers will also look into  how ongoing reforms are supporting the  good functioning of the Member States  labour markets among other measures they  will consider investing in human capital  through education and training fostering  reintegration of the long-term  unemployed as well as supporting job  creation through tax and benefit systems  the council will adopt conclusions on  inclusive labour markets and on a  strategic framework for health and  safety at work